let me give you some advice
[Music]
the process of doing your second draft
is a process of making it look like you
knew what you were doing
all along writing a novel
is like driving through the fog with one
headlight out
you can't see very far ahead of yourself
but every now and again
the mists will clear
[Music]
in my class i'm going to tell you what
stories are
i'm gonna give you some tips i'm gonna
give you some exercises
and most of all i'm gonna give you a
little push forward that you might not
have had
here we go i'll go through the whole
thing because it's fairly short and it
does a whole bunch of stuff with
character and then
i'll tell you what i did i have writer's
book
i cannot write sounds like something
that you can do nothing
about that of course isn't true why
don't i take you through
the process of plotting a comic sandman
19
i can give you how i do it and how i did
it you do it like this your thumbnails
will
only be seen by you you definitely don't
have to show them to an artist who can
actually draw
world building is honestly the joy of
getting to play god
every little detail that you can smuggle
with you into your fiction
makes your world more real for your
reader
and you know of course that just smudges
in the background that's okay because it
was informed
by you and an imagination
human beings are storytelling creatures
stories are vital we
convey truth with stories that
is the magic of fiction you need that
conviction
that you are brilliant this is the
greatest idea that anybody's ever had
and that by
writing it you will set the world on
fire
i'm neil gaiman and this is my master
[Music]
class
you